but we start in downtown las vegas with
sasha loftus where first friday
just kicked off for the first time sasha
in more than a year
brian those who love this event say it's
really just like a big homecoming as it
is
the first time in a year that everyone
has been down here together
in the arts district now like anything
else in the age of covid there will be
some changes
but it still should be a pretty good
time now one of those changes
limited capacity this is a ticketed
event now with only 250 people allowed
in the festival area at a time mass and
temperature checks
also required when you come in we have
our food trucks and vendors down here as
usual along with
some local artists first friday
organizer corey fagan tells me
first friday's comeback is really a big
boost for downtown las vegas
there's a definite economic impact by
having first friday in the arts district
not just for the local businesses that
are doing well people are supporting
these local galleries and businesses
normally which
were everyone's so grateful for but
there's so many artists out tonight that
depend on first friday that haven't been
out in a year
[Music]
now first friday just started at five
o'clock about a minute ago and it will
continue through around ten o'clock
tonight now if you are still heading
down again make sure to bring your
ticket
and your mask there is a line of people
we're seeing getting those temperature
checks
and showing their tickets to get into
the area if you're looking for parking
there is parking at art square parking
lot
that's near coolidge and arts way
reporting live downtown tonight sasha
loftis
8 news now